[Music]  every day were inundated inundated with  new photos of celebrities politicians  and ass feats many of these pictures  have been photoshopped to make this  subject look better or to remove  something embarrassing or distracting  from the probe from the shot I thought  I'd show some of this in examples in a  piece we're calling before Photoshop  there's a nice shot of Pope Francis  sitting and listening  the original tells a different story  though that's right the Pope was a  puppet being operated by Jeff Dunham it  was si that afterwards yeah here's a  photo of former Patriot Aaron Hernandez  running on the field but this is how it  looked when the criminal was without his  Photoshop we're kicked off Reno 911  - silly there's a photo of Bret Michaels  I can't do this anymore big stadium  concert but then you see the original  scene you see the fire X P thing appears  normal but now you're first comes your  way